the u.s is for now resisting a new
effort to give ukraine something it
badly needs more fighter jets poland
which is part of nato has offered to
give some of its soviet aeroplanes to
ukraine but the u.s and poland cannot
agree on exactly how to do that
christina raffini is in reshaft that's
about 50 miles west of where i'm
standing right now christina good
morning
good morning tony this announcement from
poland took american officials by
surprise mostly because it's not the
arrangement they had been discussing now
the original plan was for poland to give
its mig fighter jets to ukraine
ukrainian pilots learn on the same type
of aircraft so they'd essentially be
plug and play the u.s would then
backfill those migs and give used f-16s
to poland but the polish government
already nervous about being a transit
point for americans and nato weapons
into ukraine got worried that it could
make them a target for russia so instead
now what they're offering is to fly 28
make fighter jets to ramstein air base
in germany and saying the u.s can then
handle the delivery to ukraine but
pentagon spokesman john kirby called any
plan that involves flying jets from a
u.s or nato controlled base into
ukrainian airspace untenable that's
because the u.s and nato are trying to
not engage russia directly while also
providing material support for ukraine
it's a very delicate diplomatic dance
one vice president kamala harris is
about to step into as she lands in
poland this evening
tony we'll be looking out for the u.s
trying to avoid a wider war christina
thank you very much